Serial killers, evil spirits, and plenty of
giant explosions — these are the flicks
that you won't want to miss in 2023.
Warning: This video contains fast, flashing
images.
Viewer discretion is advised, especially for
those with photosensitive epilepsy.
Like his previous film, "Old," which is based
on a Swiss graphic novel, M. Night Shyamalan
will turn to some interesting source material
for his next film.
In the summer of 2022, it was revealed that
"Knock at the Cabin," Shyamalan's upcoming
thriller, is based on Paul Tremblay's horror
novel "The Cabin at the End of the World."
Though we don't yet know how Shyamalan's version
of the tale will twist the narrative, "The
Cabin at the End of the World" follows a couple
and their daughter as they're set upon by
a group of mysterious armed strangers at their
secluded cabin.
The invaders claim that one member of this
small family must be sacrificed in order to
save the world, leading to a tense standoff
with unimaginable consequences.
Shyamalan's film stars Jonathan Groff, Ben
Aldridge, and Kristen Cui as the family in
danger, along with Dave Bautista, Rupert Grint,
Nikki Amuka-Bird, and Abby Quinn as the home invaders.
Expect to see some truly chilling horror when
"Knock at the Cabin" arrives February 3, 2023.
The MCU's Multiverse Saga began with "Spider-Man:
No Way Home" and "Doctor Strange in the Multiverse
of Madness," but things are about to get deadly
serious in the upcoming "Ant-Man and the Wasp: Quantumania."
This time around, Scott Lang and his allies
will team up to face Kang the Conqueror, a
multiversal, time-traveling villain played
by "Lovecraft Country" star Jonathan Majors.
Majors first played the role in the form of
a character dubbed simply "He Who Remains"
at the end of "Loki" Season 1, and now, he's
returning to play another variant of the mysterious adversary.
Exactly what Kang wants — and how Scott
will end up facing him — is still a mystery.
What's not a mystery is that our heroes will
definitely be spending a lot of time in the
Quantum Realm, where they'll run into a character
played by Bill Murray.
One of Marvel's weirdest villains — the
evil oversized head called M.O.D.O.K.
— will also be showing up.
We'll find out exactly what happens next when
"Quantumania" hits theaters on February 17, 2023.
"See you soon."
Back in 2015, the world of Rocky Balboa expanded
with "Creed," in which the legendary boxer
decides to coach the son of his late friend
and rival.
Starring Michael B. Jordan as Adonis Creed,
the Ryan Coogler-directed sports drama was
a major success, earning Sylvester Stallone
his first Golden Globe.
In 2023, the "Creed" franchise is set to continue
with its third installment, building on the
first sequel in which Adonis fought the son
of Ivan Drago.
This time around, Jordan himself will also
be stepping into the director's seat, giving
him even more ownership of the sub-franchise
he helped launch.
Tessa Thompson and Phylicia Rashad will also
return as Adonis' girlfriend and stepmother,
respectively, but one person who won't be
back is Stallone himself.
With Rocky Balboa's journey seemingly wrapped
up at the end of "Creed II," it looks like
the Italian Stallion is done — at least
for now.
Across from Jordan in the ring will be Jonathan
Majors, who will serve as a new antagonist
for the series.
Adonis will enter the ring once again when
"Creed III" drops on March 3, 2023.
"Dungeons & Dragons" has long been one of
the biggest names in fantasy, so it makes
sense that a new attempt at an adaptation
of the franchise will be reaching cinemas
in 2023.
"Dungeons & Dragons: Honor Among Thieves,"
from "Game Night" writers John Francis Daley
and Jonathan Goldstein, looks like it has
the makings of a clever fantasy adventure.
"Honor Among Thieves" will follow a group
of… well, thieves, as they set out to stop
an apocalyptic event that they inadvertently
caused by stealing a dangerous artifact.
Going on this quest will be actors Chris Pine,
Michelle Rodriguez, Sophia Lillis, Justice
Smith, and Regé-Jean Page.
Of course, plenty of iconic creatures from
the role-playing game will be making appearances,
from owlbears to mimics to gelatinous cubes.
"Dungeons & Dragons: Honor Among Thieves"
sneaks into theaters also on March 3, 2023.
In the spring of 2023, four years after "Shazam!"
burst into theaters, we'll finally get a sequel
from many of the same people who made the
first film so fun.
At the end of 2019's "Shazam!", Billy Batson
gained a family of heroes to help him in his
quest to save the world.
"Say my name."
"BILLY!"
"No, not my name, no, say the name that I
say to turn into this guy!"
“SHAZAM!”
Now, the world is threatened again, and the
family will face a challenge unlike anything
they've seen before.
Instead of a mad scientist, Shazam and friends
will face off against the daughters of Atlas
— played by Helen Mirren, Lucy Liu, and
Rachel Zegler.
Many of the original major players from the
first film are also back for the second installment,
including Jack Dylan Grazer as Freddy Freeman
and Djimon Hounsou as the wizard Shazam.
We can expect another epic good time, but
don't yet know how this film will connect
with Dwayne Johnson's Black Adam, another
major player in the Shazam saga.
Regardless, "Shazam!
Fury of the Gods" hits theaters on March 17,
2023.
"How good to see you again so soon, Mr. Wick.
Shall I announce you?"
"Yes, please."
We were supposed to get the fourth chapter
of the "John Wick" saga back in 2021, but
the COVID-19 pandemic pushed things back a
bit.
Now we know that the spring of 2023 will finally
bring us the next phase of the assassin's
ever-growing story.
We don't know all that much about where "Chapter
4" will take John so far, other than the clues
left by the end of "Chapter 3."
We do know, of course, that Keanu Reeves will
return in the title role, along with Ian McShane
as Winston, Lance Reddick as Charon, and Laurence
Fishburne as the Bowery King.
Newcomers to the "John Wick" universe include
Donnie Yen, Clancy Brown, Bill Skarsgård,
Rina Sawayama, and Hiroyuki Sanada.
"John Wick" will return when "Chapter 4" hits
theaters on March 24, 2023.
A decade away from the box office didn't stop
the fifth installment of the "Scream" franchise
from being a box office hit.
It wasn't long before a sixth film was announced.
We don't know much about "Scream 6" just yet,
but filmmakers have revealed that Melissa
Barrera, Jenna Ortega, Jasmin Savoy Brown,
and Mason Gooding will all reprise their roles
from the 2022 "requel."
They'll be joined by franchise mainstay Courteney
Cox and "Scream 4's" Hayden Panettiere.
Sadly, the biggest star of the franchise,
Neve Campbell, will not be returning as Sidney
Prescott after a pay dispute.
It'll be strange to lose Sidney, but Samara
Weaving and Tony Revolori will be there to
round out the cast in her absence.
"Scream 6" will be unleashed on March 31,
2023.
After the "Dark Universe" experiment failed
with "The Mummy" in 2017, Universal Pictures
set out to craft a new approach to its classic
movie monsters, giving us films like "The
Invisible Man" in the process.
Now, they're taking some of their characters
down a very different route with "Renfield,"
a movie about one of the most famous sidekicks
in horror history.
Directed by Chris McKay and starring Nicholas
Hoult in the title role, "Renfield" will tell
the story of Count Dracula's servant, who
gets a new lease on life and a chance at his
own agency when he falls in love with a traffic
cop and sets off on an unlikely journey.
If that doesn't sound fun enough, "Renfield"
will feature the one and only Nicolas Cage
playing Count Dracula, a dream role for the
legendary actor.
"Renfield" arrives in all its vampiric glory
on April 14, 2023.
A decade after the "Evil Dead" franchise got
a reboot film from director Fede Alvarez,
Sam Raimi's Deadites are set to once again
rampage through movie theaters in "Evil Dead Rise."
This time around, the action will move to
a Los Angeles apartment building, where a
reunion between two sisters is interrupted
by an ancient book unleashing the Deadites.
The film marks the first time an "Evil Dead"
film will take things to a more urban setting,
which should be an interesting change of pace.
Writer-director Lee Cronin is responsible
for this new take on the franchise.
Now, with Sam Raimi and Bruce Campbell acting
as executive producers, it's time to see what
Cronin can do with the Deadites.
"Evil Dead Rise" invades theaters on April
21, 2023.
"Groovy."
James Gunn said back in 2017 that he would
be back for a third installment in the "Guardians
of the Galaxy" series, but we didn't know
then that the wait would be this long.
It's been a bit of a bumpy road: Gunn was
fired and eventually rehired by Marvel, but
now "Guardians of the Galaxy Vol. 3" seems
to finally be on course.
A sneak peek at San Diego Comic-Con 2022 teased
tension between Star-Lord and Gamora, as well
as an origin story for Rocket Raccoon.
In addition to all the usual suspects, "Vol.
3" will also feature Maria Bakalova as Cosmo
the Spacedog, Will Poulter as Adam Warlock,
and Chukwudi Iwuji as the High Evolutionary.
The Guardians of the Galaxy will return for
the MCU's first-ever holiday special on Disney+
during the 2022 Christmas season.
"Guardians of the Galaxy Vol. 3" will follow
in theaters a few months later, on May 5, 2023.
The "Fast Saga" has been an unstoppable franchise
juggernaut for years now, but things are finally
starting to slow down when it comes to the
story's main characters.
The upcoming tenth and eleventh installments
in the series will wrap up the story of the
Toretto family and their exciting exploits.
The usual major players are back for the penultimate
installment in the series, including Vin Diesel,
Michelle Rodriguez, Tyrese Gibson, Chris "Ludacris"
Bridges, Jordana Brewster, and Sung Kang.
They'll be joined by more recent franchise
additions like John Cena and Charlize Theron.
In terms of newcomers, the film will also
feature Jason Momoa, Brie Larson, and Rita
Moreno in key roles.
It's also the first "Fast" outing for director
Louis Leterrier, who replaced Justin Lin midway
through production.
"Family just got bigger."
"Fast X" speeds into theaters on May 19, 2023.
"Spider-Man: Into the Spider-Verse" is one
of the most acclaimed superhero films of the
past decade, a major animated hit for Sony
Pictures that won an Oscar for Best Animated
Feature and set up a whole multiverse of new
possibilities for its sequel.
In 2023, we'll finally get to see it for ourselves.
Like the first film, the sequel will feature
Miles Morales, Peter B. Parker, and Gwen Stacy
teaming up as Spider-themed heroes to save
the world — but this time around, they'll
be getting some new friends and enemies.
Oscar Isaac has returned to play Miguel O'Hara,
a.k.a.
Spider-Man 2099, a character introduced in
a post-credits scene in the first film.
Issa Rae has also joined the film as Jessica
Drew, more commonly known as Spider-Woman,
while Jason Schwartzman will play the Spider-Man
villain known as the Spot.
"Across the Spider-Verse" swings into theaters
on June 2, 2023, and will be followed up by
"Spider-Man: Beyond the Spider-Verse" in 2024.
The "Transformers" movie franchise just keeps
on transforming.
Over a decade has passed since Michael Bay
launched the live-action adaptation of the
world's favorite robots in disguise, but the
Autobots and Decepticons keep finding new
ways to make it back to the big screen.
In 2023, they'll do it for the seventh time
— and this time, they'll be joined by the Maximals.
"Transformers: Rise of the Beasts," is a '90-set
story that will introduce elements of the
popular "Beast Wars" storyline.
This time around, we'll head to Brooklyn,
where Optimus Prime will encounter some new
faces and face off against the vicious Terrorcons.
The Autobots won't be alone in the fight.
They'll have the Maximals — transforming
robots who become animals — along for the
ride for the first time, with Ron Perlman
voicing the aptly named Optimus Primal.
It's a whole new frontier of Transformers
movie storytelling, and it arrives on June 9, 2023.
A movie version of "The Flash" has been in
the works for over a decade at this point,
long enough for the character to get a whole
different life on The CW.
After a long list of screenwriters and directors
moved through the project without completing
it, the long-awaited DC Comics film starring
Ezra Miller will finally land in 2023.
We don't know much about the plot of "The
Flash" yet, but we do know that it'll feature
the DC Multiverse and bring back the Batmen
played by Ben Affleck and Michael Keaton.
We'll also see a new live-action version of
Supergirl played by Sasha Calle, setting the
stage for even more spinoff potential.
That's not what actually has people talking
about the movie, though.
"I know we're all thinking the same thing
right now.
Who's gonna say it?
I'm not gonna say it."
"The Flash" has made news more recently not
for its supporting cast or director Andy Muschietti's
vision, but for Miller's erratic behavior
and frequent run-ins with police.
Now, the question is how Warner Bros. deals
with those issues in the lead-up to the film's
impending release.
No matter the circumstances, it looks like
we'll see "The Flash" hit the ground running
on June 23, 2023.
Fifteen years after he last appeared in a
feature film, Indiana Jones will return to
the big screen for what's likely to be the
final time starring Harrison Ford.
It's been in development for years, but the
still-untitled fifth "Indiana Jones" film
is finally on track.
Although director Steven Spielberg will still
be on board as a producer, "Indy 5" marks
the first time that the Oscar winner hasn't
directed.
He turned that honor over to "Logan" helmer
James Mangold, who also co-wrote the script.
Harrison Ford, who turned 80 years old in
2022, will be joined by Mads Mikkelsen, Phoebe
Waller-Bridge, Antonio Banderas, Boyd Holbrook,
and more.
Not only will Harrison Ford almost certainly
be hanging up the hat and whip, but composer
John Williams has suggested that he might
retire after writing the score for "Indy 5."
It'll be an epic return for Indy, but it might
also be a farewell to two of the most influential
figures in film history.
"Indiana Jones 5" rolls into theaters on June
30, 2023.
The "Mission: Impossible" films have defied
the odds by getting bigger and better with
each installment.
Tom Cruise first played Ethan Hunt way back
in 1996, and since then, he's made the character
into a kind of superhero, taking on increasingly
daring real-life stunts along the way.
Now, we're about to get the biggest "Mission
Impossible" yet.
The seventh film in the series will once again
team Cruise with director Christopher McQuarrie,
the mastermind behind the previous two Missions
Impossible.
Franchise mainstays Rebecca Ferguson, Ving
Rhames, Vanessa Kirby, and Simon Pegg will
be along for the ride, along with series newcomers
Hayley Atwell, Pom Klementieff, and Holt McCallany.
Hunt's mission will tackle a global conspiracy
and redefine the very nature of truth in the
public eye.
In 2022, Cruise revealed that the film is
subtitled "Dead Reckoning Part One," setting
up a two-part adventure that won't properly
conclude until 2024.
"What's done is done…
when we say it's done."
"Mission: Impossible – Dead Reckoning Part
One" finally arrives July 14, 2023.
Christopher Nolan films are events unto themselves
nowadays, as Nolan uses every ounce of the
clout he won through his Batman blockbusters
to make grand-scale films that he might not
otherwise get the chance to tackle.
In September 2021, Nolan revealed that his
next project would be "Oppenheimer," a film
about legendary scientist J. Robert Oppenheimer
and his work creating the first atomic bombs.
Cillian Murphy, who worked with Nolan on the
"Dark Knight" trilogy and "Inception," will
play the title character during his years
in the Manhattan Project.
Meanwhile, the film's massive supporting cast
will include…
Emily Blunt, Robert Downey Jr., Matt Damon,
Florence Pugh, Rami Malek, Benny Safdie, Josh
Hartnett, Dane DeHaan, Jack Quaid, Matthew
Modine, Alden Ehrenreich, Kenneth Branagh,
David Dastmalchian, Jason Clarke, and many,
many more.
"Oppenheimer" will blow up the box office
on July 21, 2023.
"Oppenheimer" isn't the only star-studded
blockbuster that'll be hitting theaters on July 21.
Despite being based on the brand of dolls
for young girls, 2023's "Barbie" is gathering
buzz thanks to the sheer number of talented
people involved.
Oscar nominee Greta Gerwig stepped up to direct
and co-write the film alongside her partner,
fellow Oscar nominee Noah Baumbach.
When Margot Robbie and Ryan Gosling were announced
as the future Barbie and Ken, the internet
started to get really excited.
We still don't know all that much about the
plot of "Barbie," but set photos suggest a
neon-colored aesthetic inspired by the 1990s.
Robbie and Gosling will be joined by a spectacular
supporting cast, including Simu Liu, America
Ferrera, Issa Rae, Kate McKinnon, Hari Nef,
Michael Cera, and Will Ferrell.
Phase 4 of the MCU has been an interesting
project so far, as it's used both feature
films and its streaming shows on Disney+ to
introduce new characters and concepts.
Now, one of the big payoffs for these introductions
is almost here.
Directed by Nia DaCosta, "The Marvels" will
unite Carol Danvers with her best friend's
daughter, Monica Rambeau, and the newly minted
Ms. Marvel, Kamala Khan.
"My costume is near perfect, just pending
the final flourish."
"Still trying to think of that flourish."
"It'll come to me - sure it will- any second
now…"
Beyond the cast, which also includes Samuel
L. Jackson returning as Nick Fury, we don't
know much about the film's plot just yet.
Of course, Carol, Monica, and Kamala have
a lot of shared comic book history, so we
can't wait to see some sparks fly when "The
Marvels" arrives on July 28, 2023.
In the summer of 2023, the DCEU will get one
of their most interesting new additions yet:
the fan favorite "Blue Beetle."
Directed by Angel Manuel Soto, the film will
star Xolo Maridueña as Jaime Reyes, a teenager
from El Paso who encounters an alien artifact
that takes the form of a mysterious blue scarab.
When he interacts with it, it fits to his
body and grants him an alien exosuit with
extraordinary powers, turning him into the
superhero known as Blue Beetle.
Alongside Maridueña are co-stars Harvey Guillen,
Bruna Marquezine, George Lopez, and Raoul
Max Trujillo.
Plus, Susan Sarandon will be starring as a
new villain created specifically for the film.
"Blue Beetle" flies into theaters August 18,
2023.
It's been nearly a decade since "The Conjuring"
arrived in theaters, and the franchise shows
no signs of slowing down.
In addition to the three films in the main
"Conjuring" series, several spinoff movies
have now developed into sub-franchises of
their own, — most notably, the evil doll
series "Annabelle."
Now, yet another "Conjuring" offshoot is set
to move into sequel territory.
In 2023, Warner Bros. will release "The Nun
2," a continuation of the saga of the demonic
spirit Valak.
Taissa Farmiga is expected to return for the
sequel as Sister Irene, a woman battling evil
in mid-20th century Europe, while Bonnie Aarons
will once again play the evil nun.
Director Michael Chaves will helm the film,
and "Malignant" writer Akela Cooper will handle
scripting duties.
Valak will be back in time for the 2023 Halloween
season, arriving on September 8 of that year.
Ever since "Venom" dropped in 2018, Sony Pictures
has been slowly building a Marvel universe
of their own.
In 2023, we'll get two new installments in
that budding franchise, beginning with "Kraven
the Hunter," the first big-screen take on
the title character.
Discussed as a possible Spider-Man movie villain
as far back as the Sam Raimi days, Kraven
is a hunter who travels the world, taking
down the deadliest game on the planet.
That eventually leads him to Spider-Man, a
powerful adversary who Kraven sees as the
ultimate prey.
The new version of the character may not face
off against Spider-Man, but he'll be portrayed
by former Avenger Aaron Taylor-Johnson.
Alongside him will be Ariana DeBose as Calypso,
Christopher Abbott as Foreigner, and Fred
Hechinger as Kraven's half-brother Chameleon.
Alessandro Nivola and Russell Crowe are also
slated to star.
"Kraven the Hunter" will be on the prowl starting
October 6, 2023.
After reinvigorating the "Halloween" franchise
with his 2018 legacy sequel, director David
Gordon Green is turning his attention to another
iconic horror series.
In 2020, Green was announced as the director
for a new installment in "The Exorcist" franchise,
setting the stage for a story that will build
on the original film's tale of a young girl
possessed by a frightening evil.
Screen legend Ellen Burstyn will return to
play Chris MacNeil, the mother of the young
girl possessed by the demon Pazuzu in the
first film.
Now, Chris will be called upon to help another
family whose child is possessed, possibly
by the same evil force that tried to claim
her daughter decades earlier.
Joining Burstyn in the film is "Hamilton"
breakout Leslie Odom Jr., who will play the
father of the newly possessed child.
Beyond those details, we don't know much yet,
but Green's experience revisiting horror classics
makes this a project to watch out for.
The film is set to release on the very spooky
date of Friday the 13th of October 2023.
Well before his first "Dune" film was released
in the fall of 2021, filmmaker Denis Villeneuve
made it clear that he was aiming for multiple
installments: his first film was just half
of Frank Herbert's epic novel.
Now, thanks to the first movie's success,
"Dune: Part Two" is on its way, and it seems
set to present something even grander than
its predecessor.
The original film's cast are all set to reprise
their roles — save for the characters who
didn't survive the first chapter.
Joining them this time around are Florence
Pugh, who will play Princess Irulan, Austin
Butler as the Harkonnen fighter Feyd-Rautha,
Christopher Walken as the Emperor Shaddam
IV, and Lea Seydoux as Lady Margot.
The film will pick up where the first installment
left off, as Paul Atreides and his mother
join the Fremen in their fight against the
Harkonnen invasion of Arrakis.
"My road leads into the desert…
I can see it."
"Dune: Part Two" touches down on November
3, 2023.
Aquaman's been part of the DC Extended Universe
since 2016's "Batman v. Superman," but he
really exploded in popularity back in 2018
when he finally got his very own big-screen
solo adventure.
An "Aquaman" sequel was previously slated
for the 2022 holiday season, but now, we'll
have to wait an extra year to see "Aquaman
and the Lost Kingdom."
What exactly is the Lost Kingdom?
We don't know for sure yet, but we do know
that Jason Momoa's Aquaman will be teaming
up with his disgraced half-brother Orm to
fight the powerful Black Manta.
We'll also see the return of Amber Heard as
Mera, Temuera Morrison and Nicole Kidman as
Arthur's parents, Willem Dafoe as Atlantean
vizier Vulko, and Randall Park as marine biologist
Dr. Stephen Shin.
Joining the cast for the first time are Jani
Zhao, Indya Moore, and Pilou Asbæk.
Plus, Ben Affleck will reprise his role as
the Caped Crusader himself, Batman.
"Aquaman and the Lost Kingdom" will finally
reveal its secrets on Christmas Day, 2023.
Martin Scorsese's next film is a highly anticipated
reunion with two of his most frequent collaborators.
The legendary director has cast both "The
Departed" star Leonardo DiCaprio and "Taxi
Driver" star Robert De Niro in key roles for
"Killers of the Flower Moon," his upcoming
adaptation of the true-crime book of the same
name.
Based on a true story, the film is set in
1920s Oklahoma and follows the investigations
into a series of murders of Native Americans,
leading to the formation of the FBI.
Also prepare to see Jesse Plemmons give the
performance of his career, as he'll play lead
FBI investigator Tom White.
Sadly, we'll have to wait a while before we
can finally watch "Killers of the Flower Moon."
Though the film was originally expected to
have a 2022 awards season run, Deadline reported
that the release has been pushed back to some
time in 2023, probably to give the film a
world premiere at a major film festival.